Should I use alkalized water at all?
So this alkalized water,
alkalized my body.
That's really the question because you've heard
that cancer-related alkaline environment,
cancer grows in a acidic environment.
That is kind of better dogma in the alternative worlds.
Now, number one,
I totally disagree with that.
Dogma totally disagree with that statement.
Cancer does not grow because the environment is acidic,
nor does it stop growing because the environment is alkaline.
Cancer is growing because the cell is defective
in the DNA replication piece.
That's why cancer grows.
So something got inside the cell.
The end of the DNA, it goes into rapid replication
and replicates cells that are rapidly replicating.
And the rate of that replication is the speed
in which the cancer grows,
the rate in which the cancer grows.
So in a quote unquote, aggressive cancer
has a higher replication rate.
Maybe it's replicating every day.
Maybe it's replicating every hour.
That would be very aggressive cancer.
So, or maybe the cancer is replicating very slowly.
So, and our goal is to stop it from replicating
or to slow the replication cycle.
You're slowing the growth of the cancer.
That's their idea.
Though anytime cells are rapidly replicating,
they're highly metabolic.
Take a lot of energy.
It takes energy in order to do that.
When a cell produces energy
and inside that cell is a warehouse
from different small little organs called organelles
that do different things.
What is mitochondria?
Are organelles that produce energy?
Well, it also produces a lot of waste.
So that waste is then exited through the cell membrane
and into the extracellular space
where the lymphatic system then carries it away.
But since cancer is rapidly replicating,
it's producing a lot more waste typically
than your lymph system can carry away.
And when the cancer is producing a lot more waste,
that waste is more acidic, typically.
So, cancer is growing in an acidic environment
because it's producing an acidic environment.
It's not because it's acidic that it grows.
It's not something outside the cell
that's causing the cell to grow and to replicate.
So, that's a medical model.
You know, it's not something outside of you
that's causing a problem.
It's something inside of you.
Same thing with the cell.
It's not something outside of the cell
that's causing the problem.
It's something that's inside the cell
What are the nucleus in the case of cancer?
So, but it is producing a lot of acidic waste.
So, is it good to alkalize my body?
Yes, well, how would it alkalize a cancer?
Well, I would increase the ability for that cancer
to, for that site where the cancer is growing
to be able to detoxify.
So, how do I help lymph flow to the area
and to drain that out?
So, there's not a waste layer of acidic waste layer
that hinders my immune system's ability
to get lymphocytes and natural killer cells
in there to kill the cancer.
Well, you need to help with detoxification pathways.
And you don't just detoxify through the lymph.
You have to, that lymph desk to be carried back
to the blood stream the arterial system, the venous system.
And then that goes back to the liver
and has to exit through the liver phase one,
phase two, phase three pathways.
And then through the gut and then to the toilet.
So, that's why I wrote seven phases of detoxification
to help understand that you have to go through that process.
It might drink baking soda, which is much more alkaline
than alkaline water.
Is that going to help alkalize right tissue site?
Well, yes, if my cancer is in my lower esophagus or my stomach,
but is that, but the idea is you have to detoxify.
You have to get rid of that acidic slime layer
in order to be able to get things flowing
so that your lymphocytes can get in there.
So, it's not just a matter of changing the pH of the area.
It's a matter of getting rid of that detoxifying that.
So, even if I have stomach cancer,
would it be advisable to drink alkaline water,
would it be advisable to drink sodium by carbonate baking soda?
No, I don't think so.
I don't think the purpose is to change the pH of that area.
The purpose is to help get rid of that waste,
not to change the pH of it.
I think the fact that waste is acidic is really a non-issue.
Besides the fact, it's just like a physiology.
If I drink baking soda, if I eat baking soda,
I would be alkalizing the stomach.
Is that even advisable?
Drinking alkalized water, I'm alkalizing my stomach.
I'm defeating the purpose of my stomach,
cells, the thridal cells in my stomach,
producing hydrochloric acid to digest my food.
I'm alkalizing my stomach,
which is increasing the risk of Hylori infection in my stomach
and in my duodenum.
And increasing the risk of Hylori in the gut,
which then could spread throughout my body,
which Hylori is the top five causes of cordary heart disease
and arterial sclerosis.
It doesn't make it tricky.
Alkalizing your stomach makes zero physiology sense whatsoever.
It's zero.
So I just totally in disagreement with using alkalized water.
Just, I just, I don't, I'm stepping on a lot of toes,
but it just does not make any physiological sense
to me whatsoever.
And you're actually probably producing
more ill health with a person.
Now, the question's gonna go on here
because I have to answer this point.
Number two, one of the other advertised benefits
of the king and system
is that it pumps the water full of hydrogen.
Now, that's a totally different game.
So hydrogenated water is totally different
than alkalized water.
So this machine may actually hydrogenate the water too.
I have all four using hydrogenated water.
So if you wanna use hydrogenated water, all four of them.
But there's machines that use hydrogenate
that will hydrogenate your water
without alkalizing your water.
So I would highly recommend that if that's something
that you consider.
Now, I do, I don't tell people to go get hydrogen water.
We were into that for a period of time
and then all first came out.
It's, it can be costly to get a machine to do that.
And I don't know completely the benefits.
I know the one machine that I just got an email about yesterday
or the day before that they did some internal studies
with cancer patients and saw some benefits.
But I have to take a closer look at that.
That's a different thing than alkalized water.
So yes, I have got a fan of alkalized water,
not a fan of drinking baking soda, but it's so.
And you can look at about H.P.L.R.I.
and I think I just did a couple of blog posts and all that.